I don't regret staying at home and being your mom,
but I regret not getting my degree
That's why somebody's mom just enrolled in college
I'm referring to myself
I'll see you around the quad
Nobody says that, Mom
Well, bring it back
I think those dads just checked you out
He's just looking at my smock,
it tends to catch the light
Mom, you're a college girl now,
and we gotta make some changes
No, we don't know where that's been
Oh god, that's a lot of hair
Mom, let me have it
No! Oh god, no!
What are you, 20?
Oh, I'm 21!
Ok
Whoo!
I love your mom
You had sex in a library? Frank!
No, don't tell Frank!
Where?
In the stacks!
In her slacks?
No, shut up, Frank
I'm older, I'm wiser
This? Essentially a Google
Ask me anything
Turn off your vaGoogle
You're scaring me
I think my vaGoogle scared Jack last night
Oh my god
But in a good way
like when you intentionally go through a haunted house
Ew!